Conan here again with my friends,
and we're doing another
song, holiday song,
for the Get Together Foundation
to help raise money and awareness
for this terrific cause that
helps children on the holidays.
So right now we're gonna do
a classic by one of the classics.
Jimmy, should we begin?
(guitar rings)
One, two, three.
♪ Christmas, Christmas ♪
♪ Christmas ♪
(blues music)
♪ It's Christmas time, pretty baby ♪
♪ And all the snow is fallin' down ♪
♪ Well, it's Christmas time, pretty baby ♪
♪ And all the snow is on the ground ♪
♪ Well, you've been a
real good little girl, ♪
♪ 'Cause ol' Santa Claus' back in town ♪
♪ Got no sleigh or reindeer ♪
♪ No sack on my back ♪
♪ You will not see me comin' ♪
♪ In a big black Cadillac ♪
♪ It's Christmas time, pretty baby ♪
♪ When the snow is fallin' down ♪
♪ Well you've been a good little girl ♪
♪ 'Cause Santa Claus, he back in town ♪
Go Jimmy! Show 'em how it's done, son.
(guitar lead break)
♪ Hang up your pretty stockin' ♪
♪ Turn on the light ♪
♪ Santa Claus comin' ♪
♪ Down your chimney tonighty ♪
♪ Christmas time, pretty baby ♪
♪ And the snow is fallin' down ♪
♪ Well you've been a good little baby ♪
♪ Santa Claus is comin' to town ♪
(laughing)
Just wanted to be contrarian, that's all.